let's go back to let's go back to this
example the top of the page okay do me
to go back you see okay so I'm gonna use
this formula you don't have to say
Pythagoras theorem or we can just go
straight to the formula and court it and
use it right so have a look at these
guys right I'm gonna write down two
coordinates minus four sorry negative 1
negative 4 negative 1 and ok so you know
you never need to write pythagoras
anymore
but i'm emphasizing pythagoras to you so
you know where this comes from
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'll say a
B equals and I'll quote my formula like
so okay there's my formula now what will
help is sorry is this your red pen can I
picture someone's right now okay have a
look right keep you see and I'd love you
to do this as well write down those
coordinates again okay now what you do
is you label them you label all four of
these values okay you say well let's
call this one x1 y1 let's call these two
x2 y2 all right and now I'm just gonna
take all of those values and stick them
into the formula so what's great about
it it's so simple now okay it's gonna be
the square root of Y 2 minus y 1 that's
just 1 minus this one 3 minus negative 1
right which were you bent from before
right we did that when we were working
out the rise plus
I now go to my x-two minus x-one you can
see that X 2 minus X 1 5 minus negative
4 you remember we did that before right
and that's how we got nine I just fish
money to the FOA that I'll answer your
question that's the square root of 4
squared plus 9 squared that's the square
root of 16 plus 81 which is 97 they go
question I just wrote them so that I
could tell them apart that's okay
now well done well done you've done what
we've done why Trina how we just did
this is called deriving a formula right
it's more than just using one you've
actually seen where it came from
ok so this is how you actually use it
now one of the great things about this
is I like to call this the distance oil
it's a very forgiving kind of formula
it's very forgiving here's what I mean
you notice I called this one x1 y1 and I
call this x2 y2
ok and then really interesting is it
doesn't matter which one's x1 y1 and
which ones x2 y2
I could have swapped them and it
wouldn't matter get it in this can
anyone see why I still get the same
answer just what yeah exactly right
watch this so I did no paper like that
okay now let me just move it down so I
can show you this on the page ok now
watch what happens you don't have to
write this down you can just watch it
just to satisfy for yourself okay I'm
gonna start with the same pair of
coordinates a and B but suppose we swap
them around okay so suppose I call this
1 x1 y1 and this 1 x2 y2 right now watch
what happens as we march into the
distance formula ok you go a B equals
square root blah blah blah okay
get man right now I'm gonna put all my
numbers in watch what happens okay let's
see white shoe - why I want that's these
guys right - one - three oh yeah watch
watch because that's that's why it's you
now and that's why one and then I'm
gonna go - four - five okay
what's - what - three guys what
specifically
it's it's negative four isn't it like
you got two negatives they get more
negative so that's negative 4 squared
minus 4 minus 5 thats negative 9 squared
Bobby here's the cool thing when you
square them it doesn't matter whether
they're negative or not right this is
still gonna be 16 and this is still
gonna be anyone so you'll still get the
square root of 97 okay so you see what I
mean it's very forgiving because even
though this line and this line are
different what you end up with is the
same oh that's really cool it's really
really good okay there is one and one
only thing that you've got to get right
this is the trickiest thing I think okay
see our let's go back to our formula the
one thing you absolutely cannot mix up
is these guys the signs okay if you mix
up the signs for instance if you get the
plus and minus backwards maybe you make
these plus and these miss - right um
it'll totally blow up you'll get them
you'll get the wrong answer and
sometimes you get no it's not because
you have a negative number under the
square root
you'll be like what happens how do I
take the square never thinking about
okay so make sure you remember those
signs where they come from is from
Pythagoras see very good that's right I
can swap these guys around too but you
can add things in any order so it's no
problem so like I said very forgiving
okay okay well done any questions on
that
I love this got it cool